الولايات المتحده لا تزال تخوض معركه صعبه
ضد الجليد في العاصفه الثلجيه القويه التي
تضرب البلاد تواصل حصد الارواح متسببه في
خسائر ماديه جسيمه ايضا وحصله ضحايا ترتفع
شيئا فشيئا حيث وصلت الى 47 شخصا لقد
حذفهم في اثنتي عشر ولايه امريكيه وقال
دائره الارصاد الجويه الامريكيه ان حوالي
60% من سكان الولايات المتحده تلقوا
تحضيرات المتعلقه بالعاصفه كما تجاوز
مجموع الرحلات الجويه الملغات منذ بدايه
العاصفه احد عشر الف رحله وفقا لموقع
التتبع الجوي
[موسيقى]
نيويورك تاخذه المعركه الاصعب الان مع
الثلوج وتحديد المدينه سكانها محاصرون
الكهرباء
اه اتفاجا طيب
نعلم انه سيكون هناك المزيد من الارقام
الخاصه بالضحايا والتي سيتم الكشف عنها
بمجرد تاكيدها فعليا
[موسيقى]